As we go to our next game,
Super Hashtag Wars 2:
Turbo Championship Edition!
Yes! Yes!
It's too intense!
The HashtagWars are
the cornerstone of @midnight.
All three of you have proven
yourselves time and time again
to be true hashtag warriors.
That's why we're raising
the stakes with tonight's game,
Super Hashtag Wars 2:
Turbo Championship Edition!
Very excited about this.
-I don't know
if I'm gonna make it. -Yeah.
I don't know
if I'm gonna make it.
A little something we crafted
in the old @midnight labs.
Instead of a single topic, this
will be a dynamic hashtag game.
The hashtag could change at any
time, and you won't know when.
So let's get ready to pun-ble!
Very excited.
We're gonna start with
the very first hashtag game
we ever played on this program.
Also was a little assist
on this one
from our good friend
John Hodgman.
So thanks to John,
wherever you are.
#FilmPoops.
These are movies that sound like
they could be poops.
Examples might be
2 Fast, 2 Furious,
uh, The Brown Bunny,
Children of the Corn.
You get it.
Don't forget, the hashtag
will change at any time,
uh, based on my whims.
So let us begin!
Start the clock!
Go! Paul F. Tompkins.
-Wedding Crashers.
-Points.
-Jesse.
-Any Which Way But Loose.
Points. Kyle.
-Splash.
-Points. Kyle.
Tyler Perry's Meet the Browns.
-(bell dings)
-That's the bell.
#StonerVideoGames. Paul.
What if BioShock was infinite?
Points. Jesse Joyce.
-Uh, Cheech and Pong.
-Points.
-(bell dings)
-Ah, #RedneckABook.
#RedneckABook. Jesse.
-A Farewell to Sleeves.
-Points.
-Kyle.
-White Pride and Prejudice.
Points. Jesse.
-Uh, The Bourne Supremacist.
-Points.
-(bell dings) -On to our next
hashtag, #MyLoveLifeIn3Words.
#MyLoveLifeIn3Words.
Paul F. Tompkins.
-Search and destroy.
-Points.
-Kyle.
-Lube-related concussion.
Points. Jesse.
-Surprise! Chris Hansen.
-Points.
-(bell dings)
-Oh. On to the last one.
#2016In5Words. Jesse.
Uh, don't use
Charlie Sheen's toothbrush.
Points. Paul F.
Please clap. Please clap!
Please!
-(applause)
-Points. Kyle Kinane.
Uh, restraining order lifted.
Hi, Tabitha.